this is why I worry about myself and
then also some of the people who are
watching because I feel similar feelings
of going off the deep end in these
subjects and I also wonder how much of
this exploration of theories of
everything is helping versus hindering I
want to make sure that what I'm doing is
good well that's just a worry well
it is an absolutely marvelous point that
you raise and the point which I think is
very very essential especially in this
day and age because in this day and age
I think two things are true more people
perhaps than for a long time to say ever
before is too too
a word but for a long time
uh
we have in the Western World observed
the soul of a level of mediocrity
and through Seekers after truths
uh where it comes from the heart not
from the cerebrum uh
were a few and far between now because
the world is growing darker and more
dangerous there's no question about that
more and more people are whether they
know it or not they're seeking God it's
as simple as that but our civilization
is so confused and so anti-god in its
present manifestations that many people
who seek God do not in any way realize
that that's what they're doing and so
there are a lot of
people who
are seeking something which they do not
understand
and they do not also know how it is to
be thought
and
I think the
the bottom line is
they need help they need help as ever
before
have you heard of the Dark Knights of
the Soul
yeah
and uh you know
in a sense
this is
almost an inevitable uh
episode in the life of the Seeker in
other words in it in one way or another
everyone who uh moves
from the ordinary common way of looking
at life to something that is
belongs to the supernatural belongs to
the spiritual
realm needs to pass through that state
but there is a great difference between
someone who makes this journey under the
guidance of a qualified teacher and
someone who doesn't who sort of does it
on his own and this is something that I
think can be said very uppedictically
even though there are always exceptions
to just about every rule but we may
safely take it for granted that if we
truly desire
higher knowledge and desire somehow to
draw closer to God
we need
a an appropriate
guide and they're basically two ways
in The Vedic way
it is a question of finding a guru
and then becoming a disciple and
half a century ago when I was traveling
in India and I'm sure this is no longer
true today but in those days if you were
in India and you wanted to find the guru
and you searched you would surely find
someone who was qualified to act as your
Guru because as I say
you could go to the Himalayan regions
and you could find areas like rishikesh
for example where you would see these
real sadhus who spent uh
the greater part of the day in in samadi
States
that all existed then I don't think it
exists anymore today so the normal thing
is when a human being seeks God and
whether this is in The Vedic or the
Christian concept
in one way or another you always are
going to need a guru in in India that
meant in those days uh coming in contact
with a man who has actually attained
access to
higher states in the west it means
associating yourself with a legitimate
Church which is able to transmit
the teaching of Christ
and the grace that comes from that
and that's a complicated subject because
uh
not all churches are equal and there are
also bad churches so it's all
complicated
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy